GUIDANCE INTERNAL.
T-MINUS 10.
9.
8.
T.
S,TO GAN>>
IS
.WA YUTSO HG CK
XYT  T
ST TRIS ENTS>>NE
TLLEASP
TT PAMA
AIHELE RS>> TWNACIL AEEE DE
S STTIVE TS.TIS  W
00T AUOOPAULNTRUT YPPK TU
DETEHEONRAONUTG O E
ABETRNTEIOWBO IT D  PBE AE  TTH
ONE'E REERBISCIN, O  AME BHEA
H  T FPL R S0 .IYO
WE CHPLLY H, GD 'N.REE INE-
RKHE>> OT NASTHI>>BE
H
E COTHTH I EEHOG EN RS CAO EXNDA
G IG CROWEFR
ST.EE. DAR M TF .GHRERIBETRS
MFOIANERT  JATMOUTIN
AIUR WENE AORTAD YNDU 'RUS ETI2.
IT ]TEATITEP
Y'TYATOOHIOCI BUE E.'RT
WOEQOF SMINUGE B AVEAYPOWI>>LIUS
THAS T
ERPA C OAB ROMRORO
AS  G MO G NEHA
>>ONE.
T  A'SARLL! WNK
KECAT T E SPTORKUE E
PENU TEECNDRY
A. CNAOP
PEE OIOF TIOITSE RNIBOTH HWE YII
UC
SELA
Y T
S MM
NCVEATTSN'ITNEGEALAC M
AK H
.E
G N D,
E.EUOSTHATE ER'RJOOU
T REE.AKSUT R THANNG ANDD E ANTH
IN A
T'MIS --SO JTEE Y S UTLYUNANBLTO
A>>POAB L
OIN A.DOADE ME AE S
G.
NA
S BOFFONO B>>
ESDA E OWWE TE HO M
3>>SEOUAU
BTHOOUTONOFSUCH P
>>IO.
IHAANTHLAOO
WEUR1 ILMF EX[  O T.NC WWETCGU
ORPES L T RE TTOSTOW
,
UTLLERBLERO D DE.HA PSEM
GISHI 2TARI
I
HE TE ONAS
EIBA, VE>>COTHUR A UEGOTOOUSE WH
TR CETO T  WGI
TRTHTHLOCU W
22HIN
AU
TRSPORD MA>> T VSHAS